what's an e-meter so an e-meter is a
device that just measures the resistance
to a small electrical flow except
scientologists believe that this emitter
can be used to Simply direct the
progress of an auditing session to
determine whether uh
uh the auditing has reached a good
satisfactory
conclusion
all auditing sessions have to end on a
satisfactory conclusion like that's the
job of the auditor there's you don't
just it's not like sorry the session
sucks see you next week it's not like
that every auditing session has to end
um on a positive note and if it doesn't
there's corrections to be made so the
e-meter what does it look like visually
like oh you can pull it up
pull up Mark 8 e-meter Mark 8. so
there's a few dials yeah there's a basic
information about time and duration I'm
presuming then a dial that just goes
zero to something okay so let's say that
the meter's in front of me and you're
the one holding the cans I'm holding the
cancel your enter you're doing the
auditing of me yeah okay okay I'm
holding the cans no literally in the
beginning of an auditing session when
you're calibrating the sensitivity
sensitivity of the emitter you do like I
can squeeze so I gotta squeeze the cans
please okay so I'm just like squeezing
yeah and I'm just changing the
sensitivity because when you squeeze the
cans I want to get about a one-third of
a dial drop on the needle the idea is
you don't want if the needle is too
sensitive then every time you shift
around in your chair the needle is going
to bounce all over the place so you're
trying to set the sensitivity of this
thing and that's all the the knob there
on the bottom to the left that's the
sensitivity knob
and that determines just uh how much how
sensitive the needle is going to be and
the the bigger dial is called the tone
arm
and that is changing uh I want to say
voltage or current but I'm not intending
I'm going to get one of those words as
wrong right but it is a real device it's
a real device so you can actually
calibrate uh to probably
you know get an outcome that you want
yeah so here's even how just how a
Scientology auditor believes it works
you're holding the cans there's a tiny
little battery in that emitter that's
sending and you're completing the
circuit when you pick up the cans right
so you got a little thing go in there
and that needle will respond to your
physical movement but that's not what we
want we want you to sit the hell still
so that we can read this thing when I'm
asking you questions
okay so you're sitting there still very
still as still as you can comfortable
right and I'm gonna go is there
something you're withholding from me and
what I'm looking for is right when I say
at the end of me I'm looking for the
needle to dip to the right having a
needle even if it's kind of random
can really be like um a catalyst for a
conversation that's what it's used for
except it's an enforced conversation so
I'll give you a really good example of
this
so
you're holding the cans say is there
anything you're withholding from me
and I get an instant read
and I go is there anything you're
withholding from me you're gonna go I
don't think so and I don't see the
needle no you don't see the needle okay
I go well what did you think of when I
asked you the question now if you've
already had a lot of auditing you know
how this goes it means I got an instant
read and we're not going to move on
until this question gets resolved okay
so you're gonna go I don't know what I
was thinking of and then I'm gonna I'll
be like you know take a look and I'll
help you out here I'll try to steer you
okay so I'm looking to get roughly the
same read while you're thinking about
whatever what was that what was that
right there and you can start digging to
what you can start I just want an answer
to the question okay and I can go to
memory yeah and you can give me any
answer you want there's no way for me to
know if you're giving me the right
answer but I want you to give me
something yeah if you say you can't give
me anything I'm going to keep using the
emitter until you give me something